hi I'm Jim Norton I'm unshaven I look
disgusting I'm here to answer the
Internet
would you rather kill 25 kittens in a
row or one dog both would give me an
equal erection would you have sex with a
girl with no arms
I'd prefer no legs but I would take no
arms absolutely would you [ __ ] the
ugliest teacher you ever had to [ __ ] the
hottest teacher you ever had great
question I would and it'd be easy
because they're a married couple okay do
you think you could beat any creature on
earth armed with two samurai swords no
not at all
could I I couldn't be any creature no
because just you know one creature armed
to the gun would [ __ ] beat me and my
dumb samurai sword so no you'd cut a
gorilla once and he would just beat you
to death would you rather be an
extremely good-looking paralyzed person
or a hideous looking person who can walk
[ __ ] great question
good-looking paralyzed guy because if
you're ugly you still might get hit by a
car if you're paranoid if you're
paralyzed what an [ __ ] have a stroke
in the middle of the paralysis question
[Music]
would you rather be Magic Johnson or
just my regular self without AIDS I'd
rather be magic with AIDS I just never
would have told anybody would you rather
walk in on your dad having sex with a
dog or your dog having sex with your dad
neither I'd rather see my dad starring
in the mr. hands video [ __ ] no one knows
what that one is that's where the horse
[ __ ] a guy to death sorry I should
have said that instead of trying to be
all highbrow at the actual title if you
could be a ghost and haunt one person
who would it be
probably the guy who [ __ ] my
ex-girlfriend after she dumped me
I was just haunt him and I would bring
in awful things that stumped the room up
so he would blame her it's the best I
got 15 years old
30 years of stand-up and the best I have
is a smelly [ __ ] joke oh mighty I need
to up my game Jim Gaffigan sells out
arenas would you hook up with someone
with a colostomy bag again I have
already yes I really have a hundred
percent I didn't know she had one
she didn't tell me and she told me right
before we fooled around and all
completely true we didn't have sex but
guess who went down and ate [ __ ] well
right on her I was fine with I didn't
care she was a nice girl she's pretty
she might have loved me yeah but I would
not we never spoke again I dumped her
for a girl with a catheter if you get
one person
dinner'll I've a question that they had
to answer honestly on TV who or what
would you ask
I would ask Oswalt were you actually
aiming for Jackie come loudly every time
you fart or fart loudly every time you
come great question farting is always
first and I'm so proud of myself I come
the louder I fart the happier I am would
you rather have to average kids or one
kid goes on to be a pro athlete and one
kid can't read
oh absolutely chances are the one who's
the pro athlete and the one who can't
read it's the same one so I would take
the one kid I don't know how many have
[ __ ] from football players I went to
college would you rather never be able
to get off again or have the feeling you
have to [ __ ] for the rest of your life
I drink 5 cups of coffee a day I always
feel like I have to [ __ ] so I'll take
this [ __ ] feeling it feels familiar
would you rather have to tell your mom
everything you've ever done sexually or
have to show your mom or show her your
porn history I'd like to do both really
slowly
I'd like to tell her while maintaining
eye contact and then go come on mom
there's more sit down actually sit down
if you were in Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory how would you get kicked out I
would have stolen an Everlasting
Gobstopper and I would have shoved it in
my [ __ ]
have you ever tried to replicate
something you've seen in a porn and
failed miserably yes achieving an
erection
[Laughter]